EACH OTHER.
BACKHANDS IT BACK  PAUL ABLE TO
IT HOME AFTER A A MURRAY.
HE'S DOWN AND BACK ACROSSTOPPED
MURRAY.
TURNED
REGAINS CONTRTRLAY.
GAUDREAU SHOOTS!
GLOVE SAVE, MURRAY O
MEANTIME!
LOOK A SAVE WITH A LEFT PAD BY
WHAT A
COLEMAN WORKS IT OFF THE BOARD
OF
LEWIS.
HE'S LOOKING FOR A REBOUND FOR
TREVORHAT PHYSICAL OF
HAD TROUBLE.
THERE'S A BUT
TKACHUK GETS IT BACK TO
PAUL.
SHOT DEFLECTED IN  THEY SCORE!
ANOTHER GOAL FOR NICK PAUL.
SECOND OF THE GAME AND IT'S 2-0
SENATORS HAVE ON THIS LAST SHIFT
AND IT'S ALL ABOUT B
AS'S GAUDREAU.
HANIFIN BUT TO THE  AND BATHERS
AND JUST A PERFECT GOALS. D
WORST GOAL IN THE LEAGUE THIS
SEASON.
THE THIRD!
AND SPACE.
HE'S LOOKING FOR STICKS,TANEV T.
HE SHOOTS AND THAT'S  MATT
MEASURELY.
IT'S ALMOST LIKE A RESET FOR
HIM.
THIS IS A4-1 OTTAWA
FROM HIS OWNAND DONE GET A PIEC
PUCK.
CONNOR BROWN JUST PUTS HIS HEAD
DOWN, USUS
MU TO THE LEFT OF
MURRAY.
YOU CAN SEE MURRAY
TKACHUK AND A SAVE FOR MURRAY.